[Música]
agosto de 2018 un incendio en cata nica
uno de los campamentos de desplazados en
la república democrática del congo
aquí estamos a salvo pero y si no lo
estuviéramos si ahora mismo se informará
de que hay un terremoto un incendio un
ataque cuantos de los que estamos aquí
tenemos un lugar al que ir donde nos
sentimos seguros
todo es verdad
un lugar en el que nos sintamos
protegidos hablamos de un refugio no
tiene por qué ser una vivienda nos vale
cualquier techo en una cueva
en esos momentos en los que se nos
despierta el instinto de supervivencia
podemos compararnos hasta con animales
algunas especies se protegen en
madrigueras otras en nidos entre
arbustos
a mí como arquitecta siempre me ha
apasionado investigar sobre la
arquitectura animal y compararla con la
arquitectura humana en algunos casos
esta relación es más clara que en otras
pero de lo que no cabe duda nunca es de
que la necesidad primordial para
construir algo es la de protegerse o la
de proteger algo
en situaciones de emergencia cuando tu
vida corre peligro hacer lo que sea para
salvarte lo más importante es proteger
te y te olvidas de todo lo demás incluso
de tus propios principios
yo crecí rodeada de animales en contacto
directo con la naturaleza con el mar
también crecí con un valor muy fuerte
sobre el concepto del respeto gracias a
mis padres y supongo que por eso he
sentido la necesidad de apoyar siempre a
los más vulnerables a los que en mi
opinión son víctimas de alguna
injusticia de alguna falta de respeto
precisamente por eso he pasado los
últimos años de mi vida trabajando en
proyectos en situaciones de emergencia
desde la crisis del ébola en sierra
leona pasando por la guerra civil en
sudán del sur hasta la crisis que lleva
azotando a la república democrática del
congo más de 20 años y que a pesar de
todos los esfuerzos no se calma
un poco de esto sale en las noticias
allí estuve más cerca que nunca de la
muerte de la falta de humanidad pero
también estuve más cerca que nunca del
amor de la verdadera humanidad y de la
viva representación de lo que es la
resiliencia humana esa capacidad de
adaptación de superación y de querer
hacer las cosas mejor desde un lugar que
permite transformación
claro que nada de esto es posible sin
humildad
aquí en cádiz vivimos viendo pateras que
cruzan el estrecho cada noche
cuando yo veo la falta de compasión que
existe hacia esas personas me hierve la
sangre
y fue precisamente esa misma rabia la
que me llevó a trabajar en proyectos de
emergencia construyendo viviendas de
emergencia infraestructuras de agua y
saneamiento rehabilitando aldeas al fin
y al cabo protegiendo la dignidad de
estas personas
sin embargo aunque me apasione mi
trabajo en muchas ocasiones también he
sentido que iba en contra de mis
principios
cuantos de los que estamos aquí sabemos
lo importante que es proteger nuestros
bosques y océanos
pues en situaciones de emergencia casi
casi que ni te lo puedes plantear la
vida de personas está en juego y no hay
tiempo para que nada más importe
pero si importa y soy consciente de que
son diversos los tipos de impacto
ambiental que el mundo humanitario
genera y de que se están discutiendo
estrategias para cambiarlo pero yo hoy
aquí vengo a hablar de mi experiencia de
lo que voy trabajando en terreno porque
cuando algo se me estampa en la cara no
puedo mirar para otro lado y mientras se
ejecutan proyectos piloto se implementan
pequeños cambios las crisis siguen
aumentan y el planeta se agota se está
muriendo
no es nada fácil no lo es desde ginebra
nueva york donde se discuten estrategias
globales pero sobre todo no les des de
terreno donde siempre vas a contrarreloj
recuerdo perfectamente cuando llegue a
ser la leona y me lave las manos y la
suela de los zapatos al entrar en el
centro de tratamiento de bola esa agua
tenía una concentración de cloro del
0.05 por ciento que no era la más alta
que se utiliza y se estaba tirando
directamente a la tierra
eso se repetía más de mil veces al día
en ese recinto sin contar la zona en la
que se gestiona a los pacientes
no cabe duda
lo más importante es proteger a las
personas es acabar con esa epidemia como
sea y si hace falta tirar agua clorada a
la tierra se tira pero sin embargo yo
también me pregunté que si ese agua
clorada que es capaz de matar a uno de
los virus más letales se está tirando a
la tierra estamos matando algo más
entonces cuánto tiempo va a tardar en
regenerarse esa tierra cuánto tiempo
pasará para que algo vuelva a crecer de
ella si estamos matando el virus del
ébola pero algo más
y esos pensamientos en una situación de
emergencia se te pasan por la cabeza
pero no le puedes dedicar mucho tiempo
tienes que actuar inmediatamente y pasas
de ser una persona a ser una máquina
trabaja trabaja trabaja trabaja y cuando
puedas descansa pero no pienses mucho
más no hagas mucho más que luego te
agotas y no rindes
eso mismo me pasó algo parecido al tema
de cloro me pasó cuando llegue a tanto
en tanto en sudán del sur como en la
república democrática del congo
allí miles y miles de personas viven
desplazadas llevan años viviendo
desplazadas en campamentos pero son
campamentos de emergencia por lo tanto
se supone que es algo temporal por lo
tanto no se puede construir nada
permanente qué quiere decir esto que
cada año se construyen y reconstruyen
miles y miles de viviendas de emergencia
de qué material están hechas las
viviendas de emergencia de madera y
plástico hablábamos de bosques y océanos
en sudán del sur la mayoría de las
viviendas de emergencia combinan el
palos de madera con bambú los palos de
madera para la estructura principal y el
bambú para la estructura secundaria fue
entonces cuando por primera vez trabajé
con este material que era tan
desconocido para mí el bambú
sabíais que una vara de bambú en tan
solo cuatro años puede alcanzar su
máxima capacidad estructural sin embargo
cuanto tarda en la mayoría de los
árboles unos 10-15 años
claro que no todo el bambú se puede
utilizar para construir existen más de
1800 especies y en torno a unas 10 son
las que se consideran para construir
estructuras
aún así no es fascinante y una de las
especies puede llegar a los 90
centímetros al día que en tan solo seis
meses puede alcanzar los 30 metros de
altura
algunas especies alcanzan la capacidad
de tensión del acero o la capacidad de
compresión del hormigón
así que no solo es precioso sino que
también se puede utilizar para construir
se puede comer se puede utilizar para
hacer ropa papel hasta crear energía
un bosque de bambú produce el 30 por
ciento de oxígeno más que cualquier otro
bosque de la misma superficie absorbe el
doble de dióxido de carbono no es
fascinante
a mí me parece que estamos hablando de
una especie de superhéroe capaz de
resolver algunas de las mayores crisis
globales a las que nos enfrentamos hoy
en día
sin embargo
como todo superhéroe también tiene un
súper enemigo la aceptación cultural
la mayoría de nosotros si pensamos en
una construcción de bambú inmediatamente
se nos viene a la cabeza algo muy bonito
exótico
el caso es que en otros países cuando se
habla de construir con bambú
inmediatamente se piensa en un material
de pobres y esto pasa con otros
materiales naturales también
en la mayoría de los contextos
cuando se menciona natural o tradición
inmediatamente se piensa en algo viejo
pasado de moda o simplemente se rechaza
por ser algo desconocido
recuerdo la primera vez que en sudán del
sur
propuse construir una estructura
utilizando solo bambú eran un campamento
de desplazados
y todo apuntaba bien el material crece
en el país y ellos lo utilizan y encima
habíamos incluido a miembros
representantes de la comunidad en la
fase de diseño
sin embargo
algunos miembros de la comunidad no
confiaban en esta estructura me decían
que no era segura que si no tenía palos
de madera y clavos eso no era firme y yo
insistía y les explicaba las
posibilidades del bambú les enseñaba
ejemplos de otros contextos pero nada
un par de reuniones con representantes
de la comunidad y al final se decidió no
continuar con esa solución por falta de
aceptación cultural
ojos que hablamos de un campamento
tienes entonces tenía más de 40 mil
habitantes quien dice que es fácil
ponerse de acuerdo entre 40.000 personas
nosotros somos casi 1000 seríamos
capaces de ponernos de acuerdo entre sí
subir o bajar el aire acondicionado
pues imaginaros en un campamento en el
que viven hacinados
y se está discutiendo así extender un
metro más o menos su vivienda
y luego llegué a la república
democrática del congo y más de lo mismo
lo gracioso es que allí me decían que no
había mucho bambú ni muchas palmeras en
el congo uno de los países más ricos en
recursos naturales
eso sí el concepto de mucho poco es muy
relativo y normalmente como siempre lo
cotidiano lo que nos rodea no se valora
fue después de tres años frustradas
viendo como el bambú era retratada en
estos países
cuando describirme abal y aprender más
sobre él y así poder promoverlo con más
argumentos lo que no esperaba era
enamorarme del bambú
siempre se me ha considerado una
arquitecta un poco rara
y es segura supongo que será porque a mí
siempre me ha interesado más el interior
que el exterior
porque dentro de la arquitectura es
donde están las personas donde la viven
donde las sienten
por eso siempre diseño de forma
participativa escuchando sensibilizando
al fin y al cabo se construye lo que se
construya sin aceptación cultural no
será sostenible no se valorará y no se
cuidará
en los países en vías de desarrollo las
ideologías culturales son mucho más
fuertes pero esto no quiere decir que no
estén abiertos a nuevas ideas
especialmente si hablamos del medio
ambiente precisamente en estos países la
relación con la naturaleza es mucho más
estrecha es ahí donde muchas de las
habilidades del ser humano para conectar
con la naturaleza aún siguen intactas
al trabajar con el bambú así como con
otros materiales naturales se trabaja la
identidad el valor de pertenencia y esto
tiene un impacto maravilloso a nivel
social
al fin y al cabo recursos naturales y
culturales van de la mano
no existe ninguna cultura en el mundo
que no tenga relación con la tierra
entonces me vais a decir que si estas
culturas toman conciencia sobre la
problemática ambiental no van a estar
abiertas a cualquier cambio que suponga
una solución
yo he vivido personalmente
si en lugares donde crece el bambú
la población toma conciencia sobre la
problemática ambiental y reconoce las
ventajas de esta planta
entonces nos estará hablando más de
material de pobres o ricos y de
aceptación cultural entonces estar
hablando de movilización local para una
transformación global
en los últimos meses he trabajado en dos
proyectos en la parte de diseño de dos
proyectos en dos comunidades diferentes
una en bali y otra en jamaica ellos
viven rodeados de bambú
pero no lo valoran como material de
construcción
entonces les escucho presta especial
atención a lo que me cuentan los
ancianos
intento entender cómo viven cómo se
relacionan con la naturaleza y cómo esto
se representa en sus viviendas
luego discutimos sobre sobre el desastre
climático que vivimos a nivel global y
cómo esto se manifiesta a su alrededor
les presento las posibilidades del bambú
y en ese momento inmediatamente
la aceptación cultural del bambú pasa a
un segundo plano
en ese momento ya estamos juntos en un
viaje en una misión
diseñamos juntos respetando la cultura
pero también el medio ambiente
considerando la problemática ambiental
que nos afecta a todos
no es fácil no es nada fácil requiere
mucho tiempo y esfuerzo
pero es que el momento es ahora
sí porque sea difícil renunciamos a
proponer un cambio entonces estamos
perdidos
y ahora voy a contar una anécdota que
vive en bali durante mi época de
enamoramiento con el bambú la primera
vez que fui a la playa
lo primero que recibí fue una
advertencia cuidado si te bañas que
puedes una infección
una infección en el mar no se supone que
el mar lo cura todo
pues allí no allí el nivel de
contaminación es tan alto que obtienes
conciencia o tela tragas y luego lo vi
con mis propios ojos mientras buceaba y
si recuerdo el maravilloso arrecife de
coral y la mantarraya pero también
recuerdo cómo iba apartando el plástico
de mi cara y como la mantarraya abría su
boca y se lo tragaba
aquí no se ve tanto pero todos los mares
y océanos están conectados
y precisamente aquí en cádiz que casi se
respira más deberíamos de ser los
primeros protegiendo el océano
hace poco conocí a angélica una chica
jamaicana de 22 años
ella combina sus estudios con la
fabricación de pajitas de bambú
cuando tomo conciencia sobre la
problemática ambiental del plástico
decidí a experimentar en su casa
tratando pequeñas cajitas de bambú con
sus abuelos y ahora las venden
no le resulta nada fácil me contaba como
muchas veces por ser mujeres joven no la
toman en serio pero aún así ahí está al
pie del cañón
estudiando y trabajando por un cambio
hoy os invito a creer en el cambio a
escucharlos a vosotros mismos a vuestros
mayores y a sentir que con pequeñas
acciones día a día estáis servido de
ejemplo para todos para los más pequeños
sabéis vuestra bolsa encontrareis una
pajita de bambú de las de angélica
si son reutilizables y si las llevamos
con nosotros y decimos que no a las que
nos ofrecen en los bares y chiringuitos
entonces estaremos siendo parte del
cambio estaremos contribuyendo a
proteger los océanos el planeta entero y
estaremos demostrando que juntos con
respeto y determinación podemos hacer
las cosas mejor
así que seamos bambú crezcamos juntos
rápidos pero fuertes y flexibles y
adapte menos al cambio
[Aplausos]
[Música]